Marco and Jones is an assistant
professor of Middle East Studies at
Hamad bin Khalifa University but he's
also an expert on Twitter and digital
disinformation he's joining us in Doha
via Skype thanks very much indeed for
being with us as Alexei was saying in a
report there it's taken about three
years for Twitter to take action like
this why do you think it's taken it so
long Twitter of famously been very
reticent to challenge Donald Trump as
was mentioned he is Twitter's most
well-known customer his presence on
Twitter is is good for the platform in
terms of advertising revenue and Twitter
have generally been lacks in terms of
approaching or tackling fake news so
it's no surprise that they've waited so
long before addressing this it does
involve electoral interference but I'm
sort of concerned that the fact that
they've done this now that they've put a
warning on one of his tweets will just
simply make people think that Twitter
are being proactive in tackling news and
I think they will be reticent to
actually do this again with Donald Trump
it's a really way of holding Twitter to
account and making sure that this is not
just as you say are one-off but actually
it does set a precedent not only of
course for the President of the United
States but for anybody that falls under
their specific rules if you like for
doing this kind of action of course I
mean there it's very difficult to hold
Twitter to erode accounts they were a
private company operating in the u.s.
their decisions to censor content aren't
as was suggested just a reflection of
adherence to the terms of conditions how
to enforce their policy is fundamentally
political we've seen this in how they
suspend accounts abroad again engaging
in disinformation and they will be more
willing to tackle accounts that have
been raised by the US administration as
a policy issue which by default makes
them less likely to tackle those in the
US government so there is an asymmetry
and how Twitter adopt these procedures
and there is a very there's an inability
from civil society organizations across
the globe to try and hold twitter to
account it's possible through pressure
but it's very difficult and there's no
sufficient mechanisms to actually really
hold them to be more transparent about
such issues
the basis of those same mechanisms that
you've just talked about does that and
talked about does that mean that it's
going to be difficult for the White
House to do anything other than complain
when Twitter does something like this in
theory yes but we know that when Donald
Trump complains about something whether
it's press freedom or fake news then
there often is take up I think Twitter
now after Donald Trump tweeted and
criticize them for censoring free speech
will be very aware that there will be
potential consequences for this who
knows what those consequences are but
it's very clear that Trump is attempting
to intimidate them after this has
occurred do you think that as users of
Twitter and other social media platforms
that we have become very lacks in the
way in in taking responsibility for
checking facts that are given to us that
we prefer to think have things
essentially just handed to us and take
them as face value and we should
actually be taking more control back
individually I think we should as
individuals be taking more control and
responsibility for what we post and
repost however individual responsibility
is not devoid of the atmosphere in which
it operates and I think in most
certainly democratic societies or any
societies people expect a certain amount
from public officials and one of those
expectations is an adherence or respect
for the truth I think in the past three
or four years in this post truth
environment especially with the likes of
Donald Trump as president we've seen
officials with influence playing scant
regard for the integrity or the value of
truth and I think this is having an
impact on people's ability to one value
the truth but also to trust public
officials and what they say it's really
we get it really appreciating you giving
us the benefit of your expertise and
this Mark Owen Jones thanks very much
for your time